all right we have reached the end of the
show but there's just enough time for
One More Story y'all this is what I'm
liking okay so I love sharing new
artists and so does my music director
Jason Halbert he introduced me to a
singer songwriter named Aaliyah
Sheffield Who first got attention during
the pandemic Aaliyah uploaded videos of
herself singing which led to a recording
contract this Summer She released an EP
titled these songs are for anyone sick
of
Earth which is awesome say hi to aah
Sheffield
everybody hi what's up
Aaliyah hi look at your setup oh my gosh
so so you took time to do music right
during the pandemic right yes that's all
I do yes did you find yourself to be
more inspired during that time as well
um yeah I think I was more inspired to
write it was just a lot going on and
instead of ranting online I I ranted in
songs and then posted those online
instead
well I love Aaliyah's lyrics um so like
this line I AE one of your little
friends I will key your car put sugar in
your tank make you remember who I am and
who I ain't yes if you want to write a
song for me anytime I would love it I
would like I would love to I love your
voice you are amazing oh my gosh well I
feel like your lyrics could go any way
you could go R&B you could go pop you
could go country with those lines like
any of those ladies would ke your car I
think at one time any one from those
genres like I I love it thank you so
much for just being inspiring we love to
like highlight artists that maybe
everybody hasn't heard of quite yet so
thank you so much Aaliyah for joining us
today I'm loving your post right now
right yes aiyah sheeld EP these songs
are for anyone sick of Earth is out now
y'all got to check it out that title is
incredible all right everybody so
usually at this moment in the show we
give our guest $1,000 courtesy of our
season long partner pilot pin Acres of
friction the goto erasable pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show but Aaliyah is
skyrocketing to the top she's doing all
right so today it's going to be someone
in the audience so let's see who it is
again look at the monitor to see your
[Applause]
face who's it going to
be hi
oh my gosh hi Kelly hello what is your
name my name is Shayla so Shayla how do
you think you're going to spend the
money um I have loans to pay so that's
the first thing I need to cover okay um
maybe take a little bit and have fun
just like a tiny car a little piece yeah
and I also booked a trip to Greece for
next year so you're going to love it I
love Greece you're going to love it
carve about some of that money for fun
right you know be responsible like 85%
of it right I'll I'll try to be exactly
exactly well thank you so much JLA for
coming I'm so glad you got oh my
goodness all right thank you to all our
guests this hour bow Yang ktim L jod
long Laura Carol Emily poffin and all at
C good morning yall have a great day
it's not trying to change
[Music]
it
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home